IDEA THIS IS A DENAZIFICATION.
>>> WE'VE SEEN THE
HEART-BREAKING IMAGES OF MOTHERS
AND THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN
DESPERATELY TRYING TO ESCAPE
UKRAINE.
FOR SOME 23FAMILIES, THAT'S NOT
POSSIBLE.
CLARISSA WARD VISITED A HOSPITAL
WHERE THEY MOVED THE PATIENTS
UNDERGROUND AND HAVE PROMISED
NOT TO LEAVE NO MATTER HOW BAD
IT GETS.
>> Reporter: OUTSIDE THE
HOSPITAL, THE SOUND OF HEAVY
FIGHTING PIERCES THE NIGHT AIR.
THE SHELLING HAS STARTED, THIS
NURSE SAYS.
WE'RE IN THE SURGICAL DEPARTMENT
FOR NEWBORN BABIES.
IT'S SO LOUD.
EXHAUSTED STAFF HOVER NERVOUSLY
IN THE HALLWAY.
THIS IS UKRAINE'S LARGEST
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
SHUTTING DOWN IS NOT AN OPTION.
NEUROSURGEON SHOWS US THE IMPACT
OF JUST ONE WEEK OF WAR.
SO THE CHILDREN WHO ARE TOO SICK
TO BE MOVED HAVE TO STAY HERE IN
THE BASEMENT IN CASE THE
BOMBARDMENT STARTS AGAIN.
THERE ARE TEN PATIENTS CURRENTLY
BEING TREATED IN THIS
UNDERGROUND HALLWAY, AND THEY
ARE VERY SICK INDEED.
>> IS THIS YOUR DAUGHTER?
>> Reporter: ON THE FLOOR IN ONE
CORNER, WE MEET SONIA AND HER
3-MONTH-OLD DAUGHTER, MELENA.
SHE HAS A BRAIN TUMOR.
IT'S A TERRIFYING SITUATION.
WE MUST STAY UNDERGROUND AND WE
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG FOR, SHE
SAYS.
I'M ALONE HERE AT THE HOSPITAL
AND MY HUSBAND IS AT HOME WITH
MY OTHER KID.
FOR SEVEN NIGHTS SHE HAS BEEN
SLEEPING ON THIS FLOOR, AS THE
BOMBING GETS CLOSER.
SHE'S SAYING THAT THE STRESS OF
THE SITUATION HAS MEANT THAT HER
MILK HAS DRIED UP AND SO SHE'S
NOW USING FORMULA FOR HER
DAUGHTER.
WITH RESOURCES BEING DIVERTED TO
DEAL WITH TRAUMA INJURIES,
PARENTS ARE STEPPING IN TO HELP
WHERE THEY CAN.
AT ONE POINT, VALLENTIN IS
FEEDING AN UNCONSCIOUS CHILD.
HE'S SAYING THAT LITTLE BABY
THERE IS HIS LITTLE BOY, BUT
HE'S HELPING WITH THIS CHILD
BECAUSE THEIR MOTHER CAN'T BE
HERE.
I TELL HIM HE'S STRONG, THERE'S
NO OTHER WAY, HE SAYS.
GOD GIVES US STRENGTH.
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT, THE DOCTOR
OFFERS HIS PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHATEVER HE CAN, BUT
THERE ARE LIMITS.
>> IT'S REALLY VERY CHALLENGING
AND VERY TOUGH BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE GOOD CONDITIONS FOR OUR
PATIENTS.
>> IS THIS DANGEROUS FOR THEM,
THIS SITUATION?
>> YES.
AND NOT ONLY BECAUSE WE HAVE A
WAR.
THESE CONDITIONS IS NOT SUITABLE
WITH BRAIN SURGERIES.
>> Reporter: FOR NOW,
NON-ESSENTIAL PROCEDURES ARE ON
HOLD.
11-YEAR-OLD YARISLAV'S SUTURES
SHOULD HAVE BEEN REMOVED BUT THE
RISK OF INFECTION IS TOO HIGH.
HIS MOTHER TRIES TO COMFORT HIM.
I WILL MASSAGE YOU AND
EVERYTHING WILL BE OKAY, SHE
SAYS.
BUT NO ONE KNOWS HOW LONG THIS
WAR WILL LAST.
AND THESE CHILDREN CANNOT WAIT
FOREVER.
JAKE, TONIGHT WE'RE CONTINUING
TO HEAR THE CRACKLE OF GUNFIRE,
THE SOUND OF EXPLOSIONS HERE IN
THE CAPITAL AS THE FIGHTING GETS
EVER CLOSER.
NOW, THE UKRAINIANS DID MEET
WITH A RUSSIAN DELEGATION TODAY
IN BELARUS.
WE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF THAT CONVERSATION,
BUT ONE THING THEY DID SEEM TO
AGREE UPON WAS THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS IN
SOME OF THESE CITIES THAT ARE
GETTING HIT SO HARD.
THAT, OF COURSE, ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL NOT JUST FOR CHILDREN
LIKE THE ONE YOU JUST SAW IN OUR
STORY BUT FOR CHILDREN AND
CIVILIANS ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY
WHO ARE BEING BOMBARDED DAY IN
AND DAY OUT AND IT'S ONLY
GETTING WORSE, JAKE.
>> CLARISSA, WHAT CAN YOU TELL
US ABOUT THE FIGHTING HAPPENING
IN THE NORTH OF WHERE YOU ARE,
UKRAINIAN AUTHORITIES SAY A
NUMBER OF CIVILIANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED IN THE LAST DAY.
>> Reporter: IT'S HORRIFYING,
JAKE, HONESTLY.
EVERY DAY WE'RE COMBING THROUGH
THE SOCIAL MEDIA VIDEO AND CNN
WORKING HARD TO TRY TO GEO
LOCATE IT.
TODAY THERE WAS JUST A DELUGE OF
TERRIFYING IMAGES COMING IN,
PARTICULARLY FROM A TOWN OF
CHERNIV WHICH YOU MENTIONED.
THEY'RE NOW SAYING 33 PEOPLE
WERE KILLED THERE TODAY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE VIDEO THAT IS
COMING OUT, I MEAN THEY'RE TRULY
APOCALYPTIC TYPE OF SCENES.
AN APARTMENT BUILDING COMPLETELY
DESTROYED.
HARD TO IMAGINE HOW ANYONE COULD
HAVE SURVIVED THAT.
THAT IS 100 KILOMETERS OR 70
MILES OR SO NORTH OF HERE IN
KYIV, BUT WE'RE SEEING TERRIBLE
FIGHTING MUCH CLOSER TO THE
CAPITAL.
THE TOWN TO THE NORTHEAST OR
NORTHWEST, EXCUSE ME, 30 MILES
NORTHWEST OF HERE HAS ALSO SEEN
HORRENDOUS AIR STRIKES,
ARTILLERY.
AND ALSO IN THE CENTER OF THE
COUNTRY.
IF YOU RECALL, WE TALKED
YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT AND THOSE INCREDIBLY
BRAVE PEOPLE WHO WERE STANDING
OUT IN FRONT OF IT AND REFUSING
TO ALLOW THE RUSSIANS ACCESS TO
IT.
THEY HAD BROUGHT IN GARBAGE
TRUCKS TO TRY TO PREVENT TANKS
FROM MOVING ONTO THE PLANT.
WE DON'T KNOW ANY LONGER WHO IS
IN THE CONTROL OF THE PLANT BUT
THE SITUATION THERE TODAY GOT